President Trump is vacationing at his
New Jersey golf club this weekend mr.
Trump is expected to use part of the
time to drum up support for Republican
candidates in the crucial November
elections we judge Aang is covering the
president and she has the latest
we jug good morning good morning
president Trump is waking up to day two
of his ten-day vacation and Bedminster
that will be a mix of pleasure and
business as you mentioned he'll be
taking day trips to campaign for
Republican candidates who are racing in
the midterm elections in fact he arrived
in New Jersey on Thursday night after a
campaign rally in Pennsylvania and then
he spent yesterday at his Golf Club the
president also tweeted an insult to NBA
star LeBron James who said during an
interview with CNN he believes the
president is using sports to divide
people mr. Trump wrote LeBron James was
just interviewed by the dumbest man on
television Don Lemon he made LeBron look
smart which isn't easy to do the
president also touted the booming
economy job creation and unemployment
which ticked down to three point nine
percent but back in Washington his
economic advisors are dealing with an
escalating trade war with China Beijing
warned it will put tariffs on 60 billion
dollars in u.s. goods including coffee
if the US moves forward with a proposal
to place tariffs on 200 billion dollars
in Chinese imports meanwhile Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo shifted the
administration's message on North Korea
acknowledging there was still a ways to
go to get North Korea to denuclearize
president Trump has said the u.s. was
making significant progress at a
security forum in Singapore today Pompeo
shook hands with North Korea's foreign
minister and delivered a letter from
President Trump to chairman Kim also
weighing on the president pressure to
sit down for an interview with special
counsel Robert Muller in the Russia
investigation those negotiations are
ongoing and his lawyers are still
deciding how to respond to molars latest
requests which lays out all the ground
rules tonight president Trump heads to a
suburb of Columbus Ohio to campaign for
state senator who is running for
Congress back to you we just hang with
the president in New Jersey thang